con opiniones divididas así reaccionaron
los canadienses ante la victoria del
partido liberal encabezado por los
incluidos en las elecciones federales
del domingo en montreal después de
conocer los resultados el primer
ministro se dirigió a sus seguidores
algunos se mostraron optimistas
estoy muy contenta de que ganó y espero
con ansias tener otros cuatro años así
que sigue siendo mucho mejor que él en
hotel reino tool de los conservadores es
un ex militar así que no creo que sea
muy bueno para hacer un disidente ni
nada por el estilo aunque en estas
elecciones anticipadas dos años antes de
lo previsto el partido liberal logró 158
escaños en la cámara baja del parlamento
canadiense unos resultados que si bien
permiten un tercer mandato de crudo lo
dejan gobernando en minoría y pongo para
mí los liberales no tuvieron éxito no
alcanzaron la mayoría porque canadá se
ha dividido de pascal calanda en
definitiva
creo que un gobierno minoritario no
superará los dos años en el poder
seguramente volverá a las elecciones en
su nuevo mandato el primer ministro
deberá hacerle frente al descenso de su
popularidad un 36 por ciento de
aceptación según los últimos sondeos
lejos del 60 por ciento de cuando fue
elegido por primera vez en 2015 además
deberá controlar el descontento de
muchos ciudadanos por la convocatoria
anticipada de elecciones en un momento
en el que el país aún lucha por
recuperarse de los efectos de la
pandemia